bajo un sol imponente miles de mujeres
se han vuelto a salir a las calles en
Ciudad de México en el Día Internacional
de la mujer para reivindicar entre otras
cosas el cese de las múltiples
violencias que sufren a diario cada dos
horas una mujer es asesinada en México
2022 cumplió el trágico récord de más de
3.700 homicidios de mujeres sin embargo
solo el 33,7% de estos asesinatos son
investigados como feminicidios y más del
90% quedan en la impunidad Pese a que
cada día en México y en mujeres son
asesinadas por el mero hecho de ser
mujer
Yo vengo porque soy sobreviviente de
feminicidio y pido justicia para que me
agresor tenga una condena ejemplar y las
carpetas se arreglan como deben de ser
para que él pague lo que hizo las
reivindicaciones en esta jornada son
extensas las manifestantes también salen
a las calles por la paridad
institucional laboral y económica La
Brecha salarial entre mujeres y hombres
en México es del 34% más datos el 98% de
las mexicanas han sufrido acoso y
hostigamiento en el transporte público y
México es el segundo país de América
Latina con peor inserción laboral para
las mujeres salimos a marchar por todas
las compañeras que estamos representando
a la científicas porque siempre dicen
que las feministas con aquellas que
están en la ciencia o en la academia
justamente porque queremos hacer una
ciencia y una academia diferente
queremos hacer una academia En donde ya
no se replican estas prácticas machistas
Y en donde todas estemos incluidas el
gobierno mexicano ha desplegado más de
800 policías mujeres también ha blindado
edificios y estatuas mientras que aquí
en las calles de México las mujeres
compartas arengas y cánticos han vuelto
a teñir las calles del color de las
Jacarandas